is that gal in there this is a gallon  i've always wondered how much a gallon  is well it's a gallon a gallon is 128  fluid ounces and uh  they say that when you start drinking a  gallon like this it takes about a week  for your body to get used to it so for  the first week or so yeah there will be  a significant amount of urination and  then your body will get used to it i  feel hydrated i feel slightly confused i  feel lonely and scared when i go to the  toilet so much i'm scared well no wonder  but you look much sexier  20 to 28 percent sexier on the eyes and  eyebrows oh thanks i'm going to say  something here and again if you're only  listening don't be concerned but would  you mind if i suck it no go ahead here  we go it's got a big straw on it  i've noticed that from 11 till  one and from one till three if i suck it  14 times i get there  harmonize with me and hold me tight all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your host the baby you're my pearl